And finally, in other news, Amazon is getting into the beauty business,...
...opening a salon in London.
Yeah, the huge salon can hold up to 5,000 people.
It will initially be for Amazon employees only.
Appointments for the public are expected to open in the coming weeks.
Now, this comes as people in UK are struggling to find haircut appointments...
...now that COVID-19 restrictions have eased a little bit.
Guys, at every station, there's gonna be iPads...
...where you can virtually try on hair colors and hair styles...
...and then of course, buy any products you want right there at your chair.
That is amazing.
You might be able to read a book there,...
...drop off a package, get a blowout, there you go.
Amazon really is taking over the world.